continúa la crisis política en Perú
[Aplausos]
Allí se suceden enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y las fuerzas del orden
después de la entrada en vigor del
estado de emergencia decretado por el
nuevo gobierno las protestas exigen
entre otros aspectos la libertad de la
expresidente Pedro castillo y la
renuncia de su sucesora Dina boluarte a
pesar de las medidas de excepción
tomadas por el ejecutivo el descontento
no disminuye
tengo deber y derecho de defender mi
patria así sea una ignorante así no haya
estudiado así Dios no haya terminado el
colegio yo como peruana tengo el derecho
de defender mi país tengo derecho de
defender la Constitución No señores
policías los señores de Nuestra Empresa
los señores congresistas han pisoteado
mis país por su parte la mandataria
ratificó horas antes la legitimidad de
su gobierno
que reafirma mi compromiso de trabajar
por la seguridad de todo el país ni la
violencia ni el radicalismo
acabarán con un gobierno legal y
legítimo Mientras tanto la víspera un
juez de la Corte Suprema de Perú amplió
la orden de prisión preventiva contra
Castillo
preventiva por el plazo de 18 meses
contra el imputado José Pedro Castillo
terrones la medida se aplica en medio de
sospechas de Fuga que pesan sobre el
exmandatario al tratar de pedir asilo
político en la Embajada Mexicana también
en el marco del proceso penal que
afronta Castillo por presunta rebelión y
conspiración al intentar cerrar el
congreso la conformación de un gobierno
de emergencia y el reordenamiento del
sistema judicial
[Música]